charles chaumin bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous ce matin sur rtl france
alors on le disait les manifestations
ont repris suite justement renoncement
de saad hariri de former un gouvernement
quelle est la situation aujourd'hui sur
le terrain des choses se soient un peu
calmé les premières manifestations qui
ont suivi la récusation de sarniguet
essentiellement dans les quartiers et
des villages sunnites essentiellement
double hier soir on enregistré certains
vous pendre de protestation dans un
secteur zones chrétiennes mais c'est
surtout dans la capitale jeudi pandore à
tripoli où la tension est restée vive
certains milieux accuse le hezbollah de
fomenter un peu des troubles à tripoli
dans la capitale du liban non c'est les
milieux de l'opposition qui affirme
c'est évidemment par le biais de
groupuscules et des corpuscules locaux à
tripoli même lié à la tension d'hier
soir la tension était très vive donc
alors évidemment c'est ce sont des
manifestations après normale en raison
des conditions de vie sur le plan
continuer le quotidien qui sont de plus
en plus difficile en raison de la
pénurie d'essence de la pénurie de
carburant de la dégradation de la
détérioration du taux de change
d'individus banes qui a effectué un peu
plus que 90% de sa valeur en quelques
mois ce qui fait que les gens sont de se
font face à une crise sociale et
économique et financière de plus en plus
lourdes à supporter alors ça ça explique
évidemment tous ces mouvements de
protestation qui sont peut-être aussi
fomenté par secteur par secteur be nice
mais il faut admettre qu'il ya un
malaise social très profond qui n'est
pas nouveau d'ailleurs qui perdure
depuis depuis un an et demi bientôt bien
bientôt deux ans
alors saad hariri a été nommé il ya neuf
mois neuf mois de tractations pour
essayer de former justement un nouveau
gouvernement libanais
finalement il a jeté l'épongé jeudi soir
est ce que c'est une nouvelle déception
pour le peuple libanais oui évidemment
si une nouvelle déception parce que
cette crise et impasse politique dans
laquelle se trouve le pays ne fait
qu'aggraver la crise financière et
économique et ne fait qu aggraver le
malaise social
il faut rappeler ici que face à la forte
dévaluation de la livre libanaise et du
poids de la dette publique
la communauté internationale a s'est
engagé à accorder une aide économique et
financière le liban mais à la condition
qu'un gouvernement soit formé qu'un
gouvernement crédible soit formé et que
ce gouvernement m remettre en place des
réformes structurelles qui sont
réclamées par la communauté
internationale depuis 2010 huit ans en
avril 2018 déjà une reprise aidant
macron avait après organisé une
conférence internationale à paris
et cette conférence se base de gland
représenté par le gouvernement libanais
s'était engagé à fournir au liban
minettes de 11 milliards de dollars ou
des projets de structures et de
rénovation des structures de base au
haut niveau
mais cette aide là est conditionnée à
l'application de réformes structurelles
qui se font toujours attendre depuis
depuis 2018 est évidemment l'impasse
politique dans laquelle se trouve le
pays depuis cette fameuse exposition du
4 août
c'est pour ça que la convocation de la
troisième conférence internationale par
la france qui a été fixé au 4 août la
date du 4 août évidemment est très
symbolique pas c'était la date de
l'explosion gigantesque avez vous de
saint maurice
dernière question
premier ministre saad hariri parle d'un
blocage une minorité de blocage il
accuse d'ailleurs michel ronde d'entravé
justement la formation de ce
gouvernement pourquoi est ce qu'il ya un
blocage aujourd'hui au liban
effectivement ça algérie a accusé michel
ronde de provoquer ce blocage dans la
formation du gouvernement
mais les milieux de l'opposition lorsque
je parle de position s'est dit c'est
l'opposition qui rejette disons-le
entreprises iraniennes par le biais du
hezbollah au liban cette opposition là
affirme qu en fait la véritable cause du
blocage c'est c'est lars bladt qui n'a
pas intégré semble-t-il à stabiliser la
situation au liban pour des
considérations un rapport avec la
stratégie iranienne dans la région
donc l'opposition affirme que la cause
véritable de ce blocage ce n'est pas en
fait le président du chêne rond qui ne
serait qu'un paravent ou bien la regarde
et l'attitude obstructionniste facebook
qui a au nom de l instrument des
pasdaran iranien et de leur instrument
de la stratégie des pasdaran dans la
région donc pour des considérations
purement iranienne d'après l'opposition
le responsable en utilisant deux
présidents michel ronde et son camp
politique c'est à dire le lecaron 10 il
dit bloquer la situation passe en fait
d'un véritable cause ce serait
évidemment il ya des causes internes ya
des courses en rapport avec les ultras
fluence des problèmes de prérogatives
entre le pru la présidence de la
république et le premier ministre ya des
causes internes
évidemment il faut pas nier ça mais la
principale cause l'élément moteur disons
de ce blocage merci beaucoup à michel
tout va d'abord répondre à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes co rédacteur
en chef du quotidien lorrain
le jour etc